what the matrix
I used to love the Transformers I really
did when I was a kid Optimus Prime
seemed to me like everything a leader
should be intelligent compassionate and
of course capable of turning into a
truck it's been frustrating in recent
years to see the Transformers become
defined in this generation not by the
charm and personality of the original
cartoon but by the cacophonous stupidity
and visual chaos of the Michael Bay
films I always hope that video games
might be the one area where the
Transformers can be redeemed the last
transformers rise of the dark spark is
not the game that redeems them I thought
this day would never go though it's
developed by edge of reality rise of the
dark spark action is closely modelled on
developer high moons games war for
Cybertron and fall of Cybertron
narrative Lee however where this game
falls is completely unclear in some ways
it seems to exist in the same universe
as the cartoons but on the other hand
the robot designs often resemble those
from the films and there are plot
details that refer to Michael Bay's
latest opus transformers age of
extinction
the result is an incoherent story that
feels like it was cobbled together from
the spare parts of other stories the
gameplay doesn't fare much better
hi moon Cybertron games were mostly
enjoyable shooting galleries and there
were times where rise of the dark spark
seems like it might manage to be the
same playing as a variety of autobots
and decepticons over the course of the
game you unleash hot robot death on
countless enemy grunts at its best
moments rise of the dark spark is fun in
the generic and familiar way that so
many blandly competent shooters are fun
a pleasant enough way to pass the time
if you have nothing else to do there's a
good variety of weapons for you to use
and although you rarely have much
incentive to transform it's nice to have
the freedom to drive or fly away from
enemies when the action heats up
unfortunately although you move around
with a feeling of appropriate heft for a
sentient being constructed of strong and
heavy metals when you get swarmed by
enemies you go down so fast you might as
well be made of aluminum cans it drains
all the joy from being Optimus Prime to
see him crumple
almost immediately in response to enemy
fire and these poorly designed combat
encounters make victory not a matter of
playing defensively and using smart
tactics but of just trying again and
again and hoping that this time it works
out for you some sections go on for much
too long
keeping you stuck in one spot fighting
off waves of identical enemies when all
you want to do is advance and the game's
maddening checkpoints regularly require
you to play lengthy sections of
frustrating action when you fall in
battle
in fact rise of the dark spark entire
campaign goes on for too long by the
time you come to the end of its 14
chapters you'll have had enough of
shooting robots to last you at least
until the next three Transformers movies
have been released it doesn't help the
game is so unpleasant to look at and to
listen to the urban environments on
earth are so drab and simple that they
look like the miniature set of a
low-budget monster movie rather than a
real city and the sound design may drive
you insane
in one level I heard the Decepticons
shout the line let's see what you got so
many times that I decided it had to be
part of a psychological warfare campaign
meant to undermine the Autobots morale
see
there are a few merciful moments of
reprieve from the standard action like
one sequence in which as Jetfire you
must fly your way out of a structure
before a weapon goes off and another in
which you play as the massive Dinobot
Grimlock who can unleash a constant
stream of flame from his robotic jaws
this power trip feels like a reward for
slogging through so much tedious and
frustrating action but it's too little
too late
there's also escalation a cooperative
multiplayer mode in which you and up to
three other players fight off waves of
invading enemies but one wave feels very
much like another
there isn't enough variety to it to keep
it interesting for long the Transformers
are a great property one that seems like
it should lend itself to the creation of
great games but rise of the dark spark
is so sloppy and incoherent that it
feels more like a cheap knockoff than a
proper Transformers game Optimus Prime
deserves better and so do you a long
chain of improbabilities place the dark
spark into my possession when the
universe presents you with an
opportunity you must never fail to
capitalize
[Music]